thank you very much i'll thank you
Aaliyah it's really good of all of you
two to come here on a Saturday we really
appreciate it there are a lot of people
from the University here Dean's and vice
presidents and Provost's and so on and
we're all thrilled to be able to have an
occasion like this and to interact with
you and do it through a whole day so
we're very very pleased that you would
come I just want to say a few things
about the state of Columbia and talk
about the expansion and what it means
and and just a couple of other things in
general I think this is a an historic
moment for Columbia I think we have the
sort of feeling of a new century and a
new beginning and opportunities for our
institution that are really very very
special and our job is to try to help as
much as possible this very great
institution with an illustrious history
to realize its potential in this century
so it's it's a great moment before I say
something about the space and
fundraising issues and the academic
planning I want to just focus on two
things that are in the new york times
today one the passing the death of
Manning Marable and what that what that
means I mean we all feel deeply the
sense of loss when a faculty member
student staff member dies with Manning
Marable if you read that article I think
two things stand out and one is the
depth of commitment a personal
commitment that great scholars have for
their research for their writing for
their laboratory experiments
and for teaching it is an incredible
personal act of dedication to do what
Manning did to bring his biography of
Malcolm X to the point given the
personal pain and suffering that he was
enduring so you just all you have to do
is read that article and it tells you
something profound about the academic
community why it is so successful in the
world the best in the world and why
Colombia is so fortunate to be at the
very top of that higher education system
and I think the second thing it tells us
is that the value of having people who
spend their lives trying to understand
the world what's happened to it what
might happen what is true what is not
true and without making any judgment
about the correctness of the
interpretation that Manning's biography
of Malcolm X has it is extremely
important that we have in the world
institutions with people like this
incredible talent dedicated to trying to
understand the truth as they see it
according to the standards of
scholarship because we all live with
greatly oversimplified versions of
reality in our minds it's just almost
impossible to live otherwise and to have
universities like Columbia that day in
and day out are trying to make the world
more complicated because it is more
complicated is really the greatest
achievement so there's nothing I can say
today or I think any of us can say about
the institution about what we're all
dedicated to committed to that go would
go beyond just reading that article
and knowing Manning Marable the second
issue I just like to address very
briefly is the rotc the question really
is should Columbia a change in policy
with respect to having ROTC on the
campus already we have of course many
military veterans Columbia's outstanding
in this regard really notable especially
the school of general studies we have
rotc opportunities for our students in
the area there are they're really quite
developed programs for our students but
we don't have and have not had an ROTC
program housed on the campus since 1969
when as everybody in this room knows
ROTC was was told no longer welcome I
think we all realized that we're at a
set of historic moment on that front as
well that is the projected elimination
of don't ask don't tell which has been
the key stumbling block between this
relationship between universities and
ROTC that is in the process of being
changed that opens the question of the
relationship and I think the university
through this year has been admirable in
the way in which students faculty
University Senate the Council of Dean's
schools have gone about trying to
understand what should be our policy in
light of the elimination of Don't Ask
Don't Tell and I just want to highlight
that for you as a tribute to the
University and its capacity to have a
debate a discussion about this and to
reach a conclusion which I hope we will
by the end of this month columbia is a
place where almost everything is debated
nothing is left for presidents to solve
on their own or Dean's to solve on their
own everything is is debated and made it
strongly and there's no exception here
and of course that's why we all love
Columbia the University very quickly the
why is this a great moment well for a
hundred years Columbia's not had or
that's a little bit of an exaggeration
for 50 years Columbia's not had the
opportunity to grow in the way that it
physically spatially in the way that it
did at the beginning of the 20th century
and I say and many of you may have heard
me say this before but I really believe
its power Columbia became one of the
greatest institutions I think the
greatest University pound-for-pound in
the world by mid-century of the last
century precisely because it had this
chance to grow as knowledge grew and the
role of universities in American society
changed and flourished and Columbia
could expand we always want more
students we always want more faculty
because knowledge grows and it was done
very very well but it had to have the
space to do that because it was a small
college with a few professional schools
at the beginning of the 20th century but
the Morningside Heights and then the
washington heights in lamont-doherty
really made it possible to become what
it was by mid-century but since the late
60s maybe a little bit before that
Columbia has has had serious problems in
dealing with trying to expand so the
manhattanville new campus in Harlem on
the river 18 acres 6 to 7 million square
feet is a magnificent opportunity for
the institution the last stage of the
process had to go through rezoning in
the city that was not
easy and then the last stage of the
process was a litigation before the
united states supreme court involving
eminent domain against the two
businesses that were holding out and
therefore would make it impossible
really to build the campus as projected
that ended in December so all the
process is done it is now up to the
University over the next 50 years to
create this new campus which is on a
scale like Morningside Heights itself
now we have an opening phase 1 phase 2
and 3 which will happen in future
decades or for future members of the
Columbia community to decide but in
phase one which will happen over the
next five to ten years this is what you
will see the mind brain behavior
institute is led by our two Nobel Prize
winners Eric Kendall Richard axle and
another very distinguished cell
biologist calm jessalyn neuroscientist
and those three will build up what is
already one of the premier neuroscience
programs in the world to the best
neuroscience program and it will be an
interdisciplinary effort because every
other discipline thinks about the mind
though from different angles economists
do lawyers do artists do and they will
be integrated into this effort with the
gift of Don green and honor of her
husband Jerome green of 250 million
dollars the largest gift ever for a
single building that project is underway
and if you go to one hundred and twenty
fifth Street hundred and twenty ninth
Street and Broadway you will see the
beginnings of that has been approved by
the trustees we are off and there are
new gifts that we will have to announce
I hope shortly that will help establish
foundation for the programming for the
building of the academic mission next to
it or right adjacent to it or two
smaller buildings one so called the
lantern which will be the School of the
Arts that will be in another that new
building and then an older building
right across the street called Prentiss
and we will have their a theater will
have a film viewing studio will probably
have a an art gallery on the main floor
and then on the other side on Broadway
and one hundred and twenty-fifth will be
an academic conference center one of the
things we lack at Columbia's a building
with space like this for us to hold
academic meetings and conferences and
smaller venues as well and we're very
fortunate with some significant gifts
not yet quite ready to be announced very
significant gifts for both of those
projects that I believe will lead us to
be able to say very shortly that we are
going ahead with those as well so four
years from now possibly five those
buildings will open sepa has another
building we've designated for that
school were further away from success in
fundraising there but working very hard
with good prospects and then just north
of that on the new campus will be the
business school two buildings flanking
the central quadrangle which is about
the size of South Lawn and that has
received a wonderful start from a gift
of 100 billion dollars from Henry Kravis
which we announced in the fall and they
have to raise four hundred million three
hundred million more over the next year
to have that go I am absolutely
confident that they will do that we will
do that and that means over the next six
seven years that building will open that
will free up space on Morningside
Heights the uris building will go to
arts and sciences and uptown the my
brain behavior and the work there will
free up space for basic sciences there
so everybody is benefited by this the
linkages between these will be very
important but I'm confident that all of
this will enhance the basic intellectual
enterprise of Columbia now the first
step in the new space is the northwest
corner building completed by rafi omen a
02 acclaimed architectural critics
review it is quite a stunning building
and is the last building on Morningside
Heights campus under the original plan
we started this five years ago and as I
said it just opened in the fall and so
he has to have this kind of poetic
conclusion that is 115 years ago Seth lo
presided over a small ceremony that laid
the cornerstone building for low library
and at that point said it would take a
long time to complete Morningside
Heights campus well 115 years later
we've completed Morningside Heights
campus with this wonderful building and
is now already filled or all not filled
but it's on the in the way of being
filled with interdisciplinary science
nanoscience and and so on again a great
great asset for our signs and for
engineering so that will link and if you
look at it it links both visually and
and scientifically with the new my brain
behavior building that as I said will be
the first building to go up in
manhattanville you'll be able to see
both of them from each will be able to
see the other so they sort of open up to
the new campus I think the other thing
to mention going to the funding which i
think is important only as an example or
run it's emblematic of the commitment of
people to the University when we
launched the capital campaign five years
ago six years ago we we aimed very high
four billion dollars the largest of any
university in the United States except
for Stanford at 4.25 and we completed
the four billion dollar gold on i think
it was februari seventh of this year a
year early despite the Great Recession
and despite and that's the work of the
deans in this room it is the work of
staff that is really quite incredible
led by Susan Fagan and now by Fred Van
Sickle whom you will hear from shortly I
mean this is an enormous statement of
the commitment of people to Columbia
University well like any good
fundraising operation we extended the
capital campaign another two years and
raised the goal 25 billion dollars and
that's what we're now engaged in trying
to do it is also a mark of the
institution's financial strength and
commitment of people to it that the
capital campaign includes gifts
projected into the future pledges as
well as current gifts in terms of actual
current gifts we are now regularly in
the top five right after Stanford and
Harvard in the amount of money raised
every single year and that's not where
we were ten years ago we were about 13th
or 14th year in and year out and now
we're absolutely in the top five if you
look at the investment performance it's
equally stunning in the last five years
the performance of our endowment and
returns is the highest
of any institution in the country with
an endowment of a billion dollars or
more so that's how financially strong
Columbia is becoming in those particular
ways and again it's a tribute the last
thing I want to just say is the place is
thriving you hear about the number of
applicants to the college you hear about
the greatness in the schools that are
represented here there's so many things
to say about this wonderful rich large
institution with twenty-two twenty-three
thousand students and thousands of
faculty and it really quite an
impressive place but one of the things
we're trying to do is to figure out what
globalization means for Columbia and
Columbia is already very very
international has the second or third
largest international student population
of any university in the United States
we have great regional institutes we
have the school of international public
affairs public health as you will hear
has led public health schools and
universities in in international
programs every single school has rich in
its attention to global issues all that
said we all know that the world is
changing in ways very very rapidly in
China going through an industrial
revolution in a couple of generations
that took 200 years in the West on and
on this is a profound time of change and
universities are typically slow to move
we don't we don't think about things
deeply and long and we're not into just
going with what happens at the moment
nevertheless we have to be attuned to
the broader forces at work in any given
time and one of the things we're doing
is saying we're not going to go the
route of having branch campuses this is
something other universities are doing
and I can explain why another
what we're doing is setting up offices
facility's staff who are highly
sophisticated very much rooted in in the
regions and those will help our faculty
and students work on real projects real
research with local institutions and
then join all of those in a network to
think about global problems you can't
any longer the thesis is think about
Africa without thinking about China and
vice versa and you can't think about the
Middle East without thinking about
Europe and and all of this has to be
part much more part of our of our life
at Morningside Heights Washington
Heights lamont-doherty than it is
presently we now have centers of global
centers we're calling them set up and
running in Amman Jordan in mumbai india
in beijing paris and we're about we're
in the process of opening them in
istanbul in santiago chile and in
nairobi and over the next several years
i think we'll see colombia having a
stronger greater presence all over the
world and that will help us with
connecting with alumni with recruiting
students with forming new relationships
with fundraising and the like and you
should watch that and see how how the
university is developing as a global
institution so thank you very much for
being here that gives you some sense of
the exciting moment at the university
look forward to today thanks